alors on va commencer par un mini débat
en forme d'interview parallèle nous
poser à tous les trois la même question
en commençant par tous à gérard est ce
que tu crois à la chance
oui en tout cas je crois à la malchance
ouais c'est autre chose
isabelle oui moi j'en ai marre chambre
de chant oui c'est vrai marchand de mes
filles voient tous à travers les
problèmes du garçon mais bien entendu la
chance les périodes de chance existe
certains et inversement la chance et la
disponibilité eux c'est d'être là quand
la chance se présente mieux s'ils
croyaient ah oui je crois beaucoup est
ce que tu as déjà consulté un guérisseur
oui même des séries parce que étant et
que je n'y crois pas et que je ne crois
pas du tout justement à l'harmonisation
de ses chances mais au moins chance et
hazard je n'ai jamais vérifier quoi que
ce soit qui m'étonne dans ce domaine
sauf qu'il vient quand même de me dire
dans les coulisses que ce que j'ai prévu
c'était arrivé faut quand même être
cohérent dans la vie à bord
elle a prévu que ça marche très bien
pour moi cette année mais pour un
artiste dont on parle un peu moins
pendant quelques années s'il n'est pas
trop bête il travaille il fait des
choses ce serait quand même grave si
j'arrivais pas faire quelque chose c'est
comme ça quand celui ci fuit toujours a
posteriori
non mais est ce que tu as déjà consulté
un guérisseur j'ai pas eu besoin pour
l'instant je touche du bois on va 10 20
100 mais c'était tout ce diplômé de la
faculté de médecine de dakar
c'est pas tout à fait sûr tu as déjà
vécu tu penses dans une vie antérieure a
pas du tout non alors ce qui est marrant
c'est que je connais des tas de gens qui
dans la vielle envir derrière on était
napoléon oui oui tu l'as remarqué les
gens n'ont jamais été fonctionnaire où
elles ont toujours été soit alexandre le
grand ou et formule 1 tu as déjà vécu
dans une vie antérieure elizabeth comme
on le saurait
je suppute
voilà bien mais je suis journaliste
c'est désormais avec le segec tu dis que
tu crois pas au paranormal mais tu as
quand même un gène était la
réincarnation de miley stewart quand
même non sous la menace il en est
toujours vu la tête ouais bah oui parce
que j'ai fait un essai de régression en
allemagne une fois bah oui et vous avez
déjà vécu dans une vie antérieure du
tirage allez on vous raconte et croyez
moi que si j'avais vécu dans une vie
antérieure redonner ce que la vie nous
réserve plus attendre et enfin de quoi
que ce soit jamais revenue c est ce que
tu crois la magie noire à la magie noire
alors quand on dit oui c'est à dire que
je ne crois pas que ce soit suprême
normal ou paranormal mais il ya des
sorciers africains qui sont très forts
entre les poisons et la mise en scène
vise aussi prendre le tigre homme qui
croit je crois qu'on peut obtenir des
résultats mais il ya des trucs est-ce
que tu donnerais tu à photo un vieux
sorcier qui te veut du mal ou alors ce
jeu j'ai reçu docteur no longer reçues
du statut est dispersée et de temps en
temps j'ai un peu mal à la tête le matin
c'est vrai mais elisabeth niveau je
crois qu'il est très imprudent notre
taureaula à droite parce que je crois
tout à fait assez fort cela sans être
totalement manichéenne mais je crois
tout à fait parce que devant j'en ai des
preuves de sa fille scientifiquement ma
tante qui était de nos ethnologue en
afrique noire et qui a vu tué sous ses
yeux d'un petit herlin les très connus
comme ethnologue elle a vu tué sous ses
yeux à distance des poulets par des
sorciers et donc elle nous dit judy et
j'ai posé la question j'ai dit est ce
que tu crois qu'on peut aussi tuer comme
ça à l'être humain elle m'a dit oui mais
ça c'est beaucoup plus fatigant non ces
préventions qu'est ce que l'on dira
scientifique ses revenus d'intel r on ne
combat puisse être réitérée si quelqu'un
a un poids un poison pour faire tuer le
le poulet à distance c'est pas votre
temps tout vat on peut tout que ce soit
vérifié la tricherie moi j'ai vu des
choses de ce genre et je sais que dans
la religion fétichiste ont fait agir à
10 ans mais il ya des gens qui sont là
tu triches donc j'ai un moment donné m
il faut sur le poulet et j'ai vu l'état
d'ethnologue et de biologistes faire
avoir à côté de moi non mais vous vous
considérez tous venez ce que vous
n'arrivez pas à expliquer comme des
trucs non donc elisabeth tu ne donnerait
pas ta faute tu pousses un sorcier qui
devenu m'a jamais mais n'en pense rien
philippe vous croyez la magie noire
ibhulu beaucoup mais il ya des
phénomènes fabuleux par exemple
deviennent sa tante africains qui font
disparaître nous subventions dans la
journée à 2
pure allemand ses envies de table est-ce
que tu passe sous les échelles j'ai bien
sûr sans problème à banon il ya quand
même un pot de peinture qui risque de
tomber de temps en temps mais à part ça
ne fait pas de soucis ah non pas du tout
elisabeth on va sauver des chaînes
allègrement aussi sauf effectivement la
cause du
temps donné ma taille je pense même sous
les escabeaux
adapté de la peine d'apprendre que les
tordeur de petites cuillères c'était un
truc toi pas préféré que ce soit magique
finalement bien sûr lorsque mois ci chez
de la magie c'est parce que depuis tout
petit j'ai cru que mandera que tout ça
c'était vrai j'ai été déçu à force parce
que j'ai reçu de 700 sera menée soit des
trucs soit de la psychologie et les
différents processus qu'on menait et
donc j'aime et je cherche encore on
lisait bête c'est à fait de la peine
d'apprendre que les tordeur de petites
cuillères c'était un truc dont je suis
pas sûr du tout que ce soit un truc qui
l'a dit il a dit abbas croit pas on à
jacques forcément ce n'est pas parole
d'évangile
j'ai participé à une des expériences que
relate gérard majax dans son bouquin et
je peux vous dire que on a décelé
dizaines de supercherie s'agissait du
rugueux l'air et que c'est vraiment un
escroc mais je comprends cela dit alors
j'ai entendu beaucoup de bruit
différents louis alors cette expérience
nous étions plus tordus que les
cuillères
on se dit qu'un fantôme dans une maison
je cours givet qui va l'accompagner
armés j'y vais avec une équipe j'ai
monté une équipe
bester oui voilà alors on nous y allons
n'enregistrons film avec caméra
infrarouge avec
magnétophone et puis on guette on écoute
et comme par hasard n'y a jamais rien
maintenant il ya quelque chose sur 128
oui on a déjà pu jamais mais écoutez moi
j'ai assisté à quelque chose
d'épouvantable une fois dans la tour de
girolata en corse où j'étais tout seul
avec des amis je dormais seul dans la
pièce parce que j'y croyais pas du tout
aux fantômes c'est une chose est que je
me refusais de croire et effectivement à
minuit et on n'a jamais pu l'expliquer
je contacte c'était une farce de mes
copains on a vraiment entendu quelqu'un
monter avec des avec un peu inégal en
plus comme si il boitait bref il ya eu
toute la toute la commande il réagi
selon moi il n'y a jamais eu
d'explication et cette personne est
entrée dans la phase de personnes cet
esprit ou je ne sais quoi est entrée
dans la pièce près de mon lit et je dois
dire que j'étais glacé de sueur morte de
trouille sous les couvertures et j'ai
été bon c'est plus beau langage ac
serait sûrement expliqué bien entendu
être qu'il est il aurait pu vous
réchauffer parce que imaginer qu un de
vos copains veuille venir près de vous
rejoindre la nuit il va pas venir
directement ça la fout mal
qui fait ça je peux vous le dire
aujourd'hui c'était moi
vous savez un fantôme dans une maison ah
oui parce que j'aimerais bien revoir
polnareff
ils ont également souvent le moment est
ce qu'on t'a déjà amené dans des
endroits où on fait tourner les tables
aulas à peu près 60 fois oui alors
56 fois il s'est rien produit du tout
sauf que c'était vraiment pénible parce
que pendant des heures on aimerait on
attendait il n'y avait rien mais c'est
important j'ai mon permis il ya un point
est
drôlement alors justement en 4 x 4 fois
ça a marché non mais c'est plus
intéressant avant quand même oui quatre
fois sur les 466 hormis tricher alors
oui les mecs qu'on les a foutu dehors à
coups de pieds au voilà les visas bêtes
s'étaient déjà réglé entre ici les a vu
tourner les tables oui ou non mais
vraiment c'est impressionnant si à oui
moi j'ai fait ça deux fois dans ma vie
je recommencerai jamais vu c'est trop la
trouille et depuis j'ai plus jamais fait
tourner une table tellement j'ai eu peur
et il a donné son nom
lettre après lettre moment c'est fou
parce que j'étais à mille lieues de
penser à ça et on ya posé plein de
questions après il nous a répondu
pertinemment à des tas de questions dont
les enfants qui se sont révélées être
exact par la suite on attendait là ces
troubles ont été fauchés disent quelque
chose de très troublant voila l'exemple
type sur le faire exprès de normes et
chats sont fermés charmant mais d'un
mensonge par non précision parce qu'elle
les avait dit il nous a dit nous aller
mais comment ça se passait quelle est la
transmission c'est pas lui qui parle
croyez-vous avoir du sens non mais dites
nous comment ça se passerait comment ça
se passe et ben voilà alors nous étions
là nous nous joignons nous
et puis tout à fait immobile attaque
complètement immobile bien casé aller et
puis il ya quelques mois je m'en
rappelle plus avons posé la question
est-ce que quel est ce qu'un esprit est
parmi nous alors que moi par curiosité
je ne fais pas ça mais c'est pas une
voix donc qu'est ce qui s'est produit
alors on l'a demandé on dirait un verre
au milieu et on a demandé aux verts de
se déplacer vers l'est a oui nous avions
25 j'ai oublié de dire les 25 lettres de
l'alphabet qui étaient autour de la
table avec des lettres
w jaffer
bon et alors le vert à commencer j'ai
oublié de dire l'essentiel se déplacer
vers les vermines seul ou avec un doigt
tu rappelez vous c'est très important
nous aviez vos doigts sur le vert
moi je vais vous dire tout le monde a le
doigt sur le verdict avec doigt sur le
vert et alors non parce que six minutes
tandis qu'à des gens racontent la chose
en disant mais le ver avancer tout seul
c'est vrai on a tous je dois sauter et à
l'arrivée il ya quelqu'un qui bouge
parce que si on avait su s'adapter trop
personne n'est pas l'une des trois noms
mais je vous assure vous êtes sur un
mystérieux dans la mesure où quelqu'un
pousse on arrivera car ça prouve
simplement que les défunts on pourra
oublier d'alphabet voilà
est-ce que pour toi gérard le vendredi
13 est un jour particulier
ah non pas du tout pas du tout elizabeth
pour toi pour moi non plus parce que ça
dépend si le jour du vendredi 13 il ya
de mauvaise étoile ou passe rien à voir
et à 9 heures si pendant longtemps ça a
été le début de mes fins de mois
est ce que tu es un porte bonheur
surtout très en verve ou est ce que est
ce que tu as un porte bonheur sur toi
non absolument pas aucun elisabeth un
porte bonheur qu'est ce que ça veut dire
j'ai rigolé fosse à n'ont pas besoin je
voulais dire de quoi des pousse à
relever les grilles n'ont pas de gris
gris j'appellerai passé les grigris
n'ont jamais des choses que je que
j'aime porter dont je joue
symboliquement le
qui symboliquement me me plaisent par
exemple les gens ça s'est ouvert un
début de récupération
seront peut pas est-ce que votre chéri
un début d'érection un nom mais je peux
vous dire que il ya plusieurs il ya
longtemps que les séries et il m'a
jamais déçu jamais jamais jamais il m'a
permis de concrétiser mais à peu près
tous mes rêves quand j'ai vraiment envie
de quelque chose je prends mon gris gris
c'est un chéquier
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus